joining me now is Missouri Senator Josh
Hawley Senator good to see you tonight
why did it take a new age of Republicans
like yourself
um obviously Trump
to wake up to the reality of of what
Corporate America has become
since about 2000 when China joined the
WTO
you know I just think for a long time
Laura you had the old Republican
establishment the old DC establishment
that said that to the big corporations
oh we're all for that the big
corporations can do no wrong and what
we've found and what you've just been
talking about is these big corporations
they are increasingly anti-america they
are increasingly on board with the woke
agenda I mean you look at some of the
worst damage that's been done in terms
of forcing a woke agenda on the American
people and it's actually the big
corporations working with big government
and then selling out our workers to
China is part and parcel of that so
we've got to make clear we're not we're
not in favor of these multilateral
corporations no more special deals for
them no more sweetheart deals we're in
favor of America we're in favor of an
America First economic policy in America
First foreign policy and that means
doing what's good for the American
worker and also what's good for for
American values and American principles
and we ought to make that clear in the
law now here's Bank of America CEO Brian
Moynihan it's funny when it's called
Bank of America when they seem to be
doing a lot of anti-American stuff just
echoing the left's talking points on
sustainability
responsible gross requires us to work
with clients of every size and every
sector to support a just transition to a
sustainable future we all face a
transition to a secure energy
environment the private sector has the
funding the scale the long-term thinking
to help with its toughest issues
including those
Senator other than being aggressively
boring he he's clearly bought into all
this ESG nonsense that China and India
are just howling at
yeah let me just decipher that you know
for the for the person watching at home
what that means is is that you as a
working person are going to have to pay
a lot more in gas prices you're going to
have to pay double digit increases for
food you're going to have to pay for
higher energy costs to heat your home he
meanwhile will keep flying in his
private jet to Davos and all these other
places and be toasted with champagne as
a great leader I mean that's that's what
that actually means Laura this is all
about this is a war on the working class
this is a war on the people who actually
believe in America let's just call it
for what it is these corporations they
don't believe in America they're not for
America they're for themselves first and
foremost they're for the rich buddies
and therefore their globalist agenda and
it's time that we stood up and said no
to all of that let's put American
workers first for a change how about
that yeah Hagerty was great we're just
showing some video of him he was great
in this hearing as well a lot of the
Republicans did a great job I need to
get to this bill that you're proposing
Senator Hawley it would allow States
another working-class issue to deport
illegal immigrants
from the country but the Supreme Court
said in Arizona versus the U.S that
Arizona may have understandable
frustrations but the state may not
pursue policies
that undermine federal law so how are
you getting around the Court's ruling
here and the traditional view that
immigration is a federal matter
yeah so this bill would change federal
law the Supreme Court ruled that way
about 10 years ago 15 years ago based on
federal law my bill would change it say
listen if Joe Biden isn't going to
enforce our immigration laws why don't
we let the states enforce immigration
laws state of Texas would love to State
of Florida State Arizona they'd love to
enforce the immigration laws let's let
them do it let's let them secure the
Border let's let them Deport illegal
immigrants according to our laws the
states will get to make up their own
laws but they can enforce federal law
they should this bill would allow them
to do it let's take the gloves off here
let's enforce the law let's restore some
order to the Border well Martha's
Vineyard knew how to deport people off
their Island right pretty quickly
senator they didn't want anyone hanging
around there they had a lot of nice hugs
though and a lot of little photo ops
that was nice Senator thank you for
joining us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else